oh thank an exclusive it's hot 975
bootleg keV you Ready Set Radio live on
studio man Ludacris yes sir what's up
man chillin brother I know it's been a
long time i'm loving Vegas right now a
memorial day weekend we don't get any
better than memorial day weekend party
in the streets I know as always a party
in the streets here for right now
streets is on fire ass shots everywhere
you know me and girls walking around
with the bikinis and they just don't
give a damn I heard you a tour of
lollipops last night my man DJ infamous
you know me within DJ the lollipops I
know it just opened up a shout out to
everybody that came in show low I think
we do at least for 25,000 in the air
ones last night we blew lollipops the
hell up man we had the new single
jingling going on my man single itching
of course with future so you know we
just some movement going on right now we
are disturbing the peace throughout the
streets of Las Vegas talk about the new
album at Universal the last album the
battle of the sexes yeah man it was a
you know I've been a long time little
fan I wasn't the biggest fan of that
album it's a lot of your fans weren't no
I saw a lot of the fans were but it's
all good female fans loved it the female
favor that's what was for so you know
yeah much my issue since I'm on you know
I like the hip hop side of looters the
verticals absolutely and you're gonna
get a lot of that on this new album so
you get the lyrical side you get the
meat taking it to a whole nother level
cuz I've been to the mountaintop says
mama de que would say so it's time to
take it to just outer space yeah we're
girls kill it will kill it what's the
direction of the album an man if the
direction is as you say you like the
lyrical looter of course you have the
introspective luda you have the fun
looter you got the story telling Lulu I
mean it's everything all balled in one
but it's gonna come together it's in an
organized fashion and it's gonna be
right and we just got hit singles four
days we got songs that you can just buy
2 I got songs that's just straight
lyrical we got everything so it's a
complete spectrum of every damn thing
Castle suck me yeah can't wait ere
Wednesday the date as of right now we
talking 911 that's my birthday I work
well yeah but this is something else I
need to tell you we shooting fast &
furious 6 overseas and you know depend
on those dates we'll see where we're
we're gonna go with the actual date of
the album I gotta eat here I gotta be
everywhere at the same damn time so I'm
gonna try and make it happen one way or
another but either way it's gonna be
right the timing will be right when it
comes you know sep tember 11 of course
you know you know the tragedy happened
but yeah that's the same day that
blueprint came out man so you know you
gotta come you gotta come with the class
concert ever absolutely my chicken and
beer was supposed to come I think a week
after that so I was actually in New York
on 911 when the planes hit the Twin
Towers in New York 30 blocks away from
where it happens so I'm forced to change
my life so I'm with you on the classic
we don't make it HAP I remember going to
the store by fabulousness first album
and jay-z's out that same day they both
came out at the same damn yeah hey
you're you're busy do man you're doing
the movies um you got the headphone
company oh yeah so hand shoutout to
everybody who supports the soul
headphones man we are now everywhere you
can get them at bestbuy to apple stores
of course radio shack man the list goes
on and on so everybody that has been
supporting them they know that's they've
been doing it that's why we are in more
stores so make sure you get them it's
like it's five different headphones you
can get the in ears you can get the you
know the smaller ones for the kids then
you got to step up from net which the
150's and you got the 300 some prices oh
you definitely five different headphones
five different prices I lead at that's
what's up man um I wanted to talk to you
i saw your on the new bieber record that
just leaked you like delete last night
yeah i was talking to be with vonage i
don't think that was supposed to happen
I didn't think so yeah but uh yeah man
it's called all around the world you and
BJ y'all got quite the rook working
relationship man I mean what's it like
deal with that it's just like me and
usher man you know if one hit record
goes man why and some name broke and why
you know it ain't broke don't fix it so
you know we keep the going we did it
again i think this record is as you lean
you listen to it has that dance feel to
it but it still has the original field
what he's doing me again he's taking it
to a whole nother level so i think
people you know they they gonna think i
love this record one state once they get
a chance to really hear it indeed did
you get to he's kind of going to hip-hop
right he's got so many hip-hop features
on the velvet it's kind of crazy have
you heard a lot of his album i have
heard a couple songs and i'm here to let
you know he's definitely jamming with I
haven't heard I haven't heard every
thing happen it's timberlake moment
we're like Roman is ok to listen to
bieber now oh yeah definitely whatever
leg was wrong in sync it was in but now
y'all yeah he's having that moment man
hey um you know I wanted to talk to you
I know two Chainz of course you you put
him him and olive oil on playing circle
oh yeah ETP they put themselves on man
whoa Jason an outlet yes anything to
change is doing right now man you know I
always call him tit and that's the right
man that's family you know we came up
together and I'm extremely proud of a
man definitely proud of him and not you
know I everybody says he works hard and
he deserves woody what he gets i 100%
agree with that man he's been hustling
I've seen him doing it since day one so
everything artists success man is much
and well deserved congratulations to
that [__] talk to him all the time that's
what I wanted to ask you when you had
him as Park Place Urkel did you ever
like um did you ever see him as a solo
artist or did you ever think that he had
the potential to be where he is right
yeah absolutely I thought both him and
dollar boy had the potential to go solo
and you know we they were both working
on solo projects as they are now so you
know they always had it playing where
they were group but they also had
separate projects and right now it's
time you know the million man right now
absolutely and watch out for dollar boy
to say both coming man in Demon's OB and
then is is I read something as 2 Chainz
I know he helped uh on the mixtape a lot
you see like a non-runner are doing some
anti work on the album he um he brought
me some beats for the mixtape that I did
I'm twenty-one gigawatts when T 1
gigawatts so he found one of the beats
on there and that's basically you know
we put checks in people's pockets man if
his family that's what we gonna do
that's an early always trying to find
sex for my people most definitely man I
also wanted to talk to you uh about just
the dtp movement I'm from Phoenix so I
gotta thank you for allowing willy
northpole to put an album out oh yeah I
talked to him the other day too so you
know he's still working shout out willy
northpole uh that was like you know like
having an artist from phoenix drop an
album on Def Jam was a big deal
everybody in the city so absolutely man
i love phoenix to me I know you do man
I've been out there yeah first your head
Oh with the jointly game and Willie yeah
oh man
oh that's one of my favorite songs of
all the ones I've done honestly yeah you
call up the homies it's about to go down
yeah love that song it's why you said
theatre mine was your is my song
everybody has their favorite Ludacris
out and I love that I mean it's blessed
to have enough albums to have when
people say this is my favorite Ludacris
albums goes we going on number eight
right now so crazed we're gonna keep it
going that's crazy my dude hey what's up
with the situation dtp right now who
signed like bleach EP man we have a new
group by the name untitled we working
with these kids TK and cash of course we
got myself and we got a couple surprises
in the works right now so I'll be able
to tell you a lot more look at the in
the near future make some power moves
and working on the power moves man week
like I always say we just getting
started trust me on that that's what
something has yes that's what it is I
also wanted to speak with you uh you
know of course a lot when you drop the
mixtape a lot of controversy brewed up
because uh you know we can keep it
positive right now we're gonna stay off
the negativity we just gonna keep in the
positive direction right now let's do
that well what else we are a whole new
front right now well I was going I
wanted ads I know you a big shona or
label HR get your chance to chop it up
after everything went down we actually
did Manny just addressed it i believe on
BTW so we had a show in Australia as I
saw you guys on the same lineup yet yeah
we had a show in Australian we actually
got a chance to sit down so that's why i
said we just don't keep me positive
right if you want truly everything's
positive man that's what it is man hey
the drama record that uh the we in this
[__] joint yeah you tip jay-z you um
man that's like such a big look for atl
cuz i mean five years ago I mean if you
would ask me if that record already
happened I'm I get it have you been a
time all three of them would have been
on the side you know what's crazy I've
had records with tip I've had records
with jeezy I've had records with drama
none of us we have never all been on the
same exact record right and future so
you know like you said it's big for
atlanta as you see we are working and we
and we always work together so we gonna
keep that going so good it's a great
look man um I want to talk to you a
little bit about the background you have
it radio man cuz oh you know you started
off ya doing the radio I should be
interviewing you right now yeah what is
up how did you get started in the radio
games you start off as a
turn yeah I started off as an intern
because I was trying to give my music
plays so of course I looked at it as a
means to an end I felt like I'll go to
the radio station is where all the
artists and all the producers are coming
through I'll be able to slide on my
music on the under you know on the sly
so what happened was I ended up getting
the job up there because I was pretty
much the youngest person at the station
and and like just the energy that I had
was good enough for them to give me a
job and I just used that job of course
to continue giving my music to auto
people that came out there and it was
only a matter of time before it worked
out so it was kind of like here I'm
gonna get into this radio game and get
on with his music day get the checks and
then i reinvested into myself into the
album mixed mastered recorded everything
with my own money put it out independent
it was called incognegro which later
turned into changing three records and
it being called back for the first time
def jam so you know that's that's pretty
much the beginning of why I'm here right
now we're talking earlier like you said
everyone's got their favorite Lou album
what's your favorite album that you put
out my favorite album is definitely the
one that I'm about to put out man lulav
oh yeah because I feel like it's a
growth in at the end of the day I always
feel like my best work is yet to come so
when I say that I'm finishing everything
up right now it is one hundred percent
what everyone loves from all the
previous albums all bunched in one
production-wise who you working with on
album man it's so many people that I'm
working with production wise that you
know I don't want to let the cat out the
bag because we have a lot of Records to
still choose from before you get the
actual final album so I don't want to
throw out you know names and then they
don't make the album but I can
definitely say shout-out to the interns
right now because they got about four
and speaking of the interns man this
jingling record which is of course
killing Memorial Day weekend all over
the country right now ll was we ll was
who really got me into hip hop music
when I was a young whippersnapper man I
heard that song i'm bad and it's just
like I loved it so much so for me to be
able to sample his record I went and sat
down with him to get this record clear
yeah he listened to it he loved it he
said man go ahead and live make that
money is honor to me so you know the
person that put me basically in the rap
game I'm just getting the to give back
so how's ur it's a great record a lot of
girls are going to
you making a lot of money that's all
yeah absolutely yeah that's like I said
who's that lollipops last night when I
said we played it at least five times it
was a lot of ones being thrown in the
air a lot of ones popping off and I got
a jingling going on that's what it is
man Lou reversals September 11
potentially potentially 911 man fast &
furious 6 you know these movie days they
always trying to push things so we shall
see fast enough area 6 absolutely man is
discount Tokyo Drift man a man I
wouldn't in joke you say you can't Cal
Tokyo Drift that [__] was terrible you
crazy bout I'll tell you one thing fast
5 pretty much reignited yeah it's higher
every night what's your brand side you
gotta bring everybody back and then it's
all good again once you got you know Bow
Wow whoever else is in that is you know
nice on original magic we'll see i'm
just trying to see if they can type fast
five so we'll see with fat six i think
we have more sequels than Jason in a
minute its franchise is getting on it
starting to be off the damn chain that's
what it is man so yeah go get the album
absolutely on for the movie yeah yo
shout out to our Luda all of that magic
number eight man headphones yeah get the
headphones make sure you get some of
that conjure cognac I mean I mean it's
sold any clothes going on yeah yeah man
you know we love we love conjure cognac
we love coming XO we in that business
right now so for all the drinkers was
just a lot of drinkers in Vegas you
gotta do that man you smooth is there no
hangover you're like a super you know
entrepreneur man you're not super negro
okay that too um no do you think
sometimes you know I feel like certain
artists like you know they have so much
time that they put into all these side
ventures is that do you ever feel like
it might take away from the music man
you know what I honestly can say that i
think i got myself wrapped up so much in
so many businesses not knowing exactly
how much of my time it was going to take
that that is part of the reason of why
i've been gone for music for the past
two or three hundred another so you know
it was a learning experience but don't
don't get it twisted at the same time
i've been living for the past ten years
you know me like I've finally got a
chance to step back and enjoy all of the
hard work and the riches that I have
accumulated and just start having a lot
of fun but
not time to get back to work you find it
kind of challenging to us like you said
kind of be off the radar on the hip hop
you know side of things the last two
years and come back and it's like kind
of like a whole new landscape I'm an
artist I've done it before man and I
love music so much that I'm willing to
take that challenge so you know i'm
saying i love that about about music and
i'm just i'm willing to get in and like
i said i record so many different
records and i love so many different
kinds of music that it's gonna be I we
don't make it work and we don't continue
to stay ahead of the curve shouts to
lure I think you're one of the most
underrated MCS ever met a man we're
gonna dress all today if they have
patience they go look this is what it is
man if they sleeping we eventually gonna
slap them silly and wake their ass you
know people always have the discussion
is later what the hot you know that the
best rappers where I always think that
you don't get your doing that a funny
thing is after your favorite album
theater of the mind that's when those
talks started coming into play so I
appreciate everybody who rides and dies
and let everybody know they felt I was
underrated we gonna continue to slap him
silly man so it you know like we just
getting started we got time don't worry
about it it ain't over that's what I
appreciate it man just before I let you
go out like no one of my favorite songs
in high school the joint you did on the
funk flex out the block on lock Wow yeah
that was a fellas are back for the first
time album too yeah what was it was
worried about it was the last song award
amount of money in it and there was a
hidden song after that well to a man too
many hours I don't even remember what
songs are on with moms I got to get it
together much you loved thanks for
coming through and I appreciate you
brother respect